[Music]
thank you
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I'm
going to keep my intro Spiel as short as
possible because my guest today is
someone I want to ask many many
questions Danny Meyer you can find them
on Twitter at DH Meyer m-e-y-e-r is the
founder and chairman of Union Square
Hospitality Group
ushg which comprises some of New York's
most beloved and acclaimed restaurants
including Gramercy Tavern the modern
myelino and more I've been to most of
them as a strong island native I have
made the Trek several times Danny and
ushg also founded Shake Shack which you
may have heard of the modern day
roadside burger restaurant which became
a public company in 2015. Danny is the
author of The New York Times bestseller
setting the table which articulates a
set of signature business and life
principles that translate to a wide
range of Industries we'll be digging
into that he is the recipient of the
2017 Julia Child award and was named by
Time Magazine as one of 2015's 100 most
influential people Danny and ushg's
restaurants and individuals together
have won an unprecedented 28 James Beard
awards think of those as the Oscars of
food including outstanding restaurateur
in 2005.
Danny so nice to finally connect live I
know it's about time it's great to see
you and to be with you Tim I have so
many pages in front of me and so many
questions it's really just been a
challenge an embarrassment of riches in
terms of where to start but I thought I
thought I would start with Maya Lino so
little pig little piglet what is the
back story on the name
I think I was about 20 years old I got
to work for my dad who was in the travel
business
and he was selling these group tours to
Airline employees and their families it
was this crazy idea he had that he had
this niche market and he was going to
aggregate all of the kind of benefits
and discounts that you would get as an
Airline employee and package them all
together to create these tours and so by
the time my brother's sister and I each
turned 20 we were each invited by my dad
to go work as a tour guide in the city
of our choice and my sister had picked
Denmark or Copenhagen I picked Rome my
brother would later pick Paris so I'm in
Rome
and this was one of the most pivotal
parts of my entire
life experience that would probably
direct where I ended up in my career and
so I was the guy that would wake up
every single morning early go pick up
these cranky
tourists they were pilots flight
attendants baggage handlers because keep
in mind they were all Airline employees
I'd pick them up at the Rome airport
collect all their luggage get them on
the tour bus I'd get on the microphone
as a 20 year old tell them all about
what the next three days were going to
be like
you know here's how you got to hold your
purse so you don't get it stolen by a
you know someone on a motorcycle here's
what you should or should blah blah blah
so anyway
I was supposed to be taking these tours
to all the typical places like the Cameo
factories and the you know the Vatican
Museum all the stuff that was on their
itinerary
but instead I was looking at this as an
opportunity to get an education in food
so I kept going to these trotterias I
found three different trattorias that
would actually pay me a thousand Lira
per head of every guest I brought in so
I'd go get free food
at these really good restaurants and I'd
end up with 25 000 lira in my pocket
afterwards well so one of the
restaurants which was called La Taverna
Giovanni
started calling me myarino little Meyer
because they knew it was my dad's
company
and
I thought that was kind of cute
and somehow over the course of that
summer without my inexperienced ear
really picking it up
my Arena Little Meyer had somehow
changed to mayolino which means little
pig
and the reason they did that and the
joke was on me but every single time I
went to this restaurant
my favorite thing to order was the
myelino the roast suckling pig
and so fast forward many many years
later
on my 50th birthday my wife Audrey she
knows I hate surprises so the party was
not a surprise but what was a surprise
to me
is that she had co-created
a logo for my birthday which was myolino
and she had my picture as a little kid
with a pig underneath it and made these
stickers for
you know bottles of wine that everybody
was drinking that night and it was such
a damn good logo
that when it was time to open a new
restaurant
I couldn't come up with a better name or
logo so we ended up naming a restaurant
monolino after this whole experience so
you can call me little pig or little
Meyer I'll answer to either one
now in the course of doing homework for
this conversation I spotted and this is
true for I suppose everyone on some
level but sliding door moments you've
had so many different sliding door
moments where your life could have cut
one way or was headed One Direction and
then seemed to pull a right or a left
turn at 90 degrees but before I get to
asking about one of those specifically
your uncle and prepping for the lsats
you mentioned you hate surprises why do
you hate surprises or how do you think
about surprises I think you know
underneath it I'm a little bit of a
control freak and I realized that you
know there's this great expression my
grandfather taught me many times which
is
man plans and God laughs
so as much as you think that you're
planning for success or planning for you
know the stuff that's going to work out
the world usually has another idea for
you so on the other hand look I if if
we're driving I like to be behind the
wheel
it's just it's my wiring so I never mind
not knowing where the story is going to
end
but I like to have some at least it may
be a false sense but I like to have some
sense that at least I had some say in
the matter
so I mean I'll be flying on an airplane
and it's not that I need to get in the
cockpit with a pilot but
for example I'm the absolute world's
worst sleeper on airplanes I've got the
window open it's almost as if I'm I'm
afraid I'm going to miss one of the
clouds outside the window if I don't
keep paying attention
I think I share some similar programming
and it brings to mind for me this
this metaphor that a novelist once
shared with me which was writing a novel
is like driving a car across country
with the headlights on you can't see
where you're going but you see enough in
front of you that at least you know
you're headed in the right direction
so coming back to what I alluded to a
little bit earlier and I I know that
we're establishing setting the table as
it were for people listening who may not
have a whole lot of background
he studied political science this if I'm
getting my facts straight
then at one point you were preparing for
the lsats so you're thinking of pursuing
law education perhaps becoming a lawyer
and you had a conversation with your
uncle could you describe that
conversation and then I have a few
follow-ups sure yeah I mean with a poli
SCI degree and the reason that I did
study political science is you know as a
child of the pretty much the 1970s
middle child of three in the middle most
state in the country Missouri
Republican dad Democratic mom
every night at the dinner table there
was a quote-unquote discussion about
politics it could have been discussed it
could have been Watergate it could have
been Vietnam
and the the dinner table was where our
our family
we could agree on what we wanted to eat
and that was kind of about it
and the food was the food was the
comfort
and I as a middle child I was I was the
one who wanted to make everybody feel
good and bring everybody together and
keep the family together and on the
other hand
as much as my dad and I were best Pals
played a lot of sports together
just you know we loved we cooked
together all the time
it was the time I spent with my mom
hanging out watching the news every
night that I found most interesting and
so I knew I loved what we used to call
current events
that just was taken by it and so after I
graduated with my Poli SCI degree I was
either going to be interested in going
into politics because what else do you
do with with that kind of degree or
maybe I was going to go into journalism
I just liked either writing about or
impacting the events of the day so
after I spent a few years being a
Salesman just to make some money selling
electronic tags to stop shoplifters of
all things
I said you know what that's not what you
want to do the rest of your life
that's been good you made a bunch of
commissions and I actually invested all
those commissions in that company stock
which was a good thing but I said you
got to do something right now so I did
take the lsats I decided law degree
instead of Journalism degree
and I first of all I think anyone who
knows me knows I would have made the
world's worst lawyer because I just
don't like I don't wake up every morning
saying I'm looking for a fight I'm
looking to prosecute
kind of the opposite I think hospitality
is the opposite which is how do we bring
people together but
it was on the eve of taking my lsats I
had taken the Kaplan course preparing
for them and everything hated every
minute of it and the night before going
to take this test was a Friday night and
I was out to dinner with my aunt and
uncle and my my grandmother in New York
City at a Italian restaurant I still go
to called Elio's
and uh
and I was in a foul just awful mood
because first of all I didn't want to
take the test didn't want to be a lawyer
and my my table mates were all having a
great time eating good pasta drinking
lots of wine and I couldn't do it so
it's a certain point my uncle
my Uncle Richard turns me and he says
what the hell is bothering you anyway
and I said
I've got to take my LSAT tomorrow
morning and he said well of course you
do you want to be a lawyer don't you and
I said actually no
and he basically he wanted to throw his
pasta spoon at me at that moment and he
asked me what was to this day the most
impactful question of my whole life
which was
one I was not expecting he said do you
have any idea how long you're gonna be
dead anyway
and I said no I hadn't really thought
about that why and he said
I don't know either but I'll tell you
one thing you're going to be dead a hell
of a lot longer than you're going to be
alive why in the world would you do
something that you have no passion
around
and I stopped and I said because I guess
I don't know what else I could do
and within a second he said you got to
be kidding me all I've heard you talk
about your entire life
is food
and restaurants and I said so what am I
supposed to
eat in restaurants the rest of my life
it was so obvious and I yet I could not
see this
and he said no you fool you should go
open a restaurant it had never dawned on
me that that was a valid thing to do
because that's not what you ever heard
about in college back then you didn't
hear about
going to open a restaurant now I'm
really really glad that all these years
later
being in the food business has become a
validated
entrepreneurial career choice for people
within education
but it wasn't back then and it's still
well I'll cut to the chase I did take
the LSAT the next morning I had already
paid for it for God's sakes never
applied to one school
but what I did do is the following
Monday morning
I connected with one of my best buddies
from Trinity College
who I used to go out to eat with all the
time he was a fraternity brother
and I said I got this idea I'm going to
open a restaurant you be you be the
money guy I'll be the food guy what do
you think
and he was in a bank training program at
that point and he said okay I'll do it
so we enrolled in the New York
restaurant School
which was you know
all you had to do was pay your 150 bucks
and you got in
and we took a restaurant management
class and he promptly dropped out after
two sessions because he made the mistake
of telling his parents that he was
thinking about leaving banking to go
into the restaurant business
and
bottom line is he felt so bad about
leaving me all alone that he said look
our our bank has one restaurant client
which was a big deal because mostly
Banks would run the other way if they
heard the word restaurant back then
and he said I'll be glad to see if I can
get you an interview with with that
would you like that
so I got the interview the interview
pretty much consisted of the owner
sitting Midway down his bar
I'm at the front door
he waves me down the bar
tells me to stop and stand right in
front of him he looks me up and down
from my wallabies up to my Brooks
Brothers shirt
and he goes
you'll do
that was my first job interview I got
the job
and I was assistant lunch manager which
meant nothing which meant I was getting
250 bucks a week to answer
reservation lines and set up the
reservation book for lunch and be on the
front door
here's the good news out of that deal
I've I've figured out in seven months
that I love this business
I met the woman who would become my wife
she was a waitress an actress
she actually left on day two to go get
an acting job and I couldn't stop
thinking about having just seen her for
one second
I I met the neighborhood in which Union
Square Cafe and Gramercy Tavern and so
many of our restaurants have been
and
I met my career and
that was a major major Pivot Point
but it just shows you so many things in
life
are those those moments I mean the fact
that that none of this ever would have
happened
if I had not gone to Trinity College for
example because that's where I met my
friend and I was over three applying I
was such a screw-up in high school
I applied to only three colleges I was
rejected from two
and wait listed at Trinity
and I had to get down on my hands and
knees and write the best
letter of my life to get off the wait
list of Trinity
so first of all that had to happen
and the only reason the Trinity happened
is that when my dad's business was in
Rome his travel business
he met Trinity College's lawyer at
dinner one night and the lawyer said hey
your son should consider Trinity College
which none of us had ever heard of
so all that stuff and then by the way
this this friend of mine
who introduced me to his restaurant
client
the only reason we ever met is on the
first night that I was at Trinity
College there's a pickup softball game
and there weren't enough baseball gloves
to go around and so I let my glove and I
went up to this guy and accused him of
stealing my baseball glove and somehow
we became friends after that so he's
just all these moments that didn't have
to happen and that it happens in life
every day and you just got to pay
attention and just be grateful
you know if if you're fortunate enough
to have a good choice based on stuff
that never should have happened in the
first place
yeah it's so wild and I so I have a
number of follow-up questions which will
will dig a bit more into a few of these
bits and pieces
so the the first is and this will lead
to a question about not applying to law
school
when you were working in Rome and you
would say have a group of four or five
people you pick the crankiest and they
become your not Mark but your objectives
in the sense that you're gonna you're
gonna turn them into a a happy raving
fan by the end
what were the keys or techniques what
did you learn over time as most reliable
for doing that for that person
I was probably in five different schools
growing up in St Louis so there was a
nursery school then there was a public
school then we moved so there was
another Public School
then I went to an all-boy school because
I wanted to play football on their team
and then 10th grade came and I wanted to
go to school with girls so I went to a
co-ed school after that
so that was five schools and then you
know by the time I was 18 now I'm going
to college so now I'm in six schools by
the time I'm 18
you gotta learn a lot of social cues
along the way and I'd just found it I
was really good at
kind of understanding what made people
tick and a really good Observer of
body language moods Etc and it's not
that I didn't have a sense of myself
where I was I wasn't like zelig or a
chameleon changing who I was but I knew
what people needed and you know kind of
a blessing to have found a career where
that is a really useful thing to be able
to do and as I said even before
going into the restaurant business for
three years I was the top salesman in
this company as a you know young 20 year
old selling against
hardened salesmen from around the
country
I just loved I loved it I loved like
getting into my little blue rabbit and
traveling to the worst neighborhoods in
New York where there was the worst
amount of shoplifting
in meeting these people these
shopkeepers who were on drugstores
bookstores
clothing stores fur stores
supermarkets and learning to speak their
language and
making the sale I just I just loved it
so I just think that I'm cut out to do
this and the fact that I happen to love
food and and wine as much as I do has
certainly helped a lot
so I would agree for sure that you are
well well cut
to
excel in these various areas and there
have been various points where you've
had to for lack of a better term maybe
operationalize or externalize yourself
so that you could say expand in the
restaurant business so I'm curious I
mean you mentioned making ends meet I
was going to say that was checkpoint am
I getting that right checkpoint systems
check my systems if you had to try to
break down what you did let's just say
in in sales at checkpoint systems that
made you so successful so that you could
teach somebody else
does anything come to mind that you
think
somebody else could emulate or
principles perhaps they could attempt to
implement if they were in that same job
well the first thing is
keep in mind this was before we had the
internet
but I would still do a lot of research
and I would still learn as much as I
could possibly learn not only about
the business that I was trying to sell
but the person who I'd be meeting with
and
what I came to learn very very quickly
in the New York retail world and keep in
mind I was primarily selling to
retailers because that's who had the
shoplifting issues
is that many many of them
who were either related to each other
there was a huge Syrian Jew population
that was not the only population but I
started to develop a sense for the
family trees of either real families or
relationships
and I got to know who knew who and I
would
you know take that as far as I could
possibly take it so I learned early on
something that has
been something that I teach our teams
even in the restaurant business we call
it a b c d so you can ABCD always be
collecting dots so you can always be
connecting dots
and I learned early on that people will
take exactly as much interest in you as
they believe you're taking in them no
more and no less
um
look I don't want to give away all my
Trade Secrets here Tim but I've listened
to your show for a long time but I
listened you know to a couple more
segments much more recently because I
really want to understand
more about what makes you tick I don't
look at it as gaming the system I think
it's genuinely being curious and being
interested and so if you're looking for
one tip it's curiosity and I should
throw in one other thing the real trick
was since I was often cold calling
people I would actually make my own
schedule for where I was going to go
that day based on a restaurant that I
wanted to try in that particular Borough
or neighborhood of New York and I would
organize my day around my lunch
or sometimes I'd organize it you know I
even organize it around some guy who
would bring in lobsters in Brooklyn at
exactly
you know two in the afternoon and I'd go
get his lobsters and bring him home to
cook but it's it in a weird way I was
developing two careers at the same time
without even thinking about it
you're collecting dots in a few
different areas at the same time
and also giving yourself it seems like
small rewards which would probably give
you more endurance in doing what you
were doing in terms of gathering or
organizing your schedule around those
lunch spots
how did you navigate the conversation
and how did your parents respond to the
conversation related to not applying to
law school
well it was easy at first because I
didn't tell them
I kind of sidetracked and sidestepped
and and
I finally at one day got the courage to
to say that I wanted to be a chef they
knew I love to cook now you may say well
how would you get the courage to say you
want to be a chef but not to be a
restaurateur
well in fact I thought I did want to be
a chef
and I had seen at that point there were
there were a number of
really well-educated
people who had gone into the culinary
profession and chefs were starting to
become
kind of well known and we keep in mind
this was way before the Food Network
but you know you had people like Alice
Waters who had gone to Berkeley you had
Jeremiah Tower who had gone to Harvard
Joyce Goldstein on the west coast
Mark Miller
on and on and on there's probably like
15 of them Wolfgang Puck had become a
household name
Paul Prudhomme in New Orleans have
become a household name so I finally got
gathered the courage to say I think I
want to be a chef and by the way in
these days I spent almost all of my time
walking around the city looking at menus
on restaurants I memorized every menu
I ate at many of the restaurants
if I you know that I would go back to
Italy many many times not just when I
was a tour guide working for my dad but
you know until the till I was 21 years
old I can travel
anywhere Pan Am flew for 44 a round trip
thanks to my Dad's Travel business and
so I was constantly
going to restaurants and learning and
learning and learning
anyway so I I finally said I'm going to
be a chef and so my dad was kind of open
to it my mom maybe a little bit less so
but
you know I went for it my dad actually
connected me with two of the relay in
chateau
colleagues of his in Bordeaux he he said
look
I know you want to go to Italy but in
Italy
you know they basically cook food with
three ingredients and that's the genius
of Italian cooking
but if you really really want to learn
to cook you got to go to France so I
said well let me do both so I spent time
in Rome bologna Sardinia Milan
and then my dad did connect me with a
restaurateur in Bordeaux named
and he had two restaurants in Bordeaux
one was called La Reserve the other
restaurant is called dubern d-u-b-e-r-n
the day before I got to La Reserve they
had lost their second Michelin star now
chefs have actually
gone off the deep end for Less because
the Michelin stars were everything for
the French
and so I get there and everybody in the
kitchen is like completely dejected and
I'm this guy who doesn't know anything
about cooking and
who is he and how did he get in our
kitchen and why are they letting him
live with the chef
and the good news was that after a
couple days a bunch of people in that
kitchen left because they did not want
their resume to say one star to be
tarnished so they figured if they left
with two stars on their resume they'd be
fine
and so all of a sudden I started to get
some opportunities some really big
opportunities like chopping shallots and
opening oysters and pulling feathers out
of pigeons
you know to prepare them and
and here was the big one I got to cook
Family Meal which was
that's a big deal to get to cook for all
the other Cooks and I was doing some of
my family's favorite recipes I'll never
forget when I made barbecued ribs they
didn't even know how to eat these things
you know it was just a great great
experience they took me to oyster beds
they took me to
chateaus and Bordeaux
they took me to places where they made
sausage
they took me on a like one of my
favorite days of my life
a day that the restaurant was closed to
go hunting for wild pigeons called palom
just a great life experience
it might be helpful to people listening
and I'd certainly love to hear your
thoughts on
for lack of a better way to put it free
work so
in the in the food world you have people
who will stash and maybe you could
describe what that means but my
understanding based on Bill gurley's our
mutual friend bill gurley's
speech at UT I think it's called Running
Down a Dream might have a slightly
different title to it but I recommend
everybody see it there's a 10 minute
segment on on your Arc and he presents
it really well and he talks about how
you went from Star salesman
at checkpoint systems and then over time
got to zero and then kind of went upside
down because I think some of these
restaurants asked you to pay them for
the privilege of working there could you
just speak to the the logic or thinking
behind that maybe it's as simple as hey
I didn't have a choice and I really
wanted to do this but it seems to me
that a lot of younger Generations now
have the impulse to say I want to be
paid what I'm worth and I see a lot of
wisdom and value in the secret weapon
that a lot of young people have when
they don't have a lot of money but they
have a lot of time which is working for
free and learning a lot
would you be able to share any thoughts
that you have on that
in our industry there's a sense that if
you really want to dig your roots and
and build a career you should learn from
the best and and how do you get your
foot in the door with the best so you
were willing to
to work for nothing
the only time I ever had to pay anybody
was this cooking teacher in Milan who
told me that she was the Julia Child of
Italy which
she certainly was not the Julia Child of
Italy
I paid her my money and moved on but I
did many many stages where I was not
paid anything
and as I told you the one that I did in
New York City
I was paid 250 bucks a week which
kind of laughable that's that's what a
waiter makes in half of a night in New
York City these days
so look I just think that if I've
learned one thing
it took me 10 years to open a second
restaurant
and you know today we'll probably open
two Shake Shacks somewhere in the world
if I've learned any one thing is that
there's a benefit to being a little bit
patient and
try to grow where you're planted and I
think that
as life is accelerated for so many
reasons
technology being
primary amongst those I think that
people feel like there has to be a
beginning middle and an end it all gets
resolved within you know a 30-minute
sitcom and that's just not how life
works and I think that
if you can do time paid or not
but but really learn what it is you're
trying to do and not scratch the surface
and move on too quickly it really pays
big dividends
now there were reasons it took me 10
years to open a second restaurant
primary one was
I didn't want to go bankrupt and since I
had seen my dad
go through two different bankruptcies
one in my teens and one when I was about
20 20 something I forget how old I was
and I always Associated as bankruptcies
with expansion and I assumed that that
was the business thing you wanted to
avoid was expansion and I didn't want to
end up like my dad I just said there's
no way I'm ever going to open a second
restaurant because I just I don't want
that to happen
and the silver lining in that
even though I eventually after after my
dad died I got some therapy and I first
thing I learned was hey guess what
you're not your dad and number two
there's a whole lot of businesses that
have expanded
and that wasn't the reason they went
bankrupt in fact they didn't go bankrupt
but
the Silver Lining was I really learned
my business I really learned it you know
that's probably the reason it took us
five years to open a second Shake Shack
I didn't want to expand too quickly and
I did not want anything bad to happen
but guess what we learned our business
this might seem like a naive question
but what does learning the business look
like
because there's there's experience and
then there's developing expertise like
some people can repeat the same mistakes
for every year for 20 years straight and
then there's
learning a lot well every business is
made up of five stakeholders and so when
I say learning the business it's
learning as much as you possibly can
about how to motivate all five of your
stakeholders to root for your success
that's what you want and so the best way
to motivate all five of those
stakeholders to root for your success is
to make sure that they believe you're on
their side first so it was learning
who's our staff that was our first
stakeholder who are they who are the
best staff we could possibly have
who are our guests and I mean really
learning about them
and to this day to this very day
I end every single night
reading all the reservation reports for
all of our restaurants so I know who's
dining in our restaurants tomorrow
and then I either if I stay up really
late I read all the the after service
reports
or I'll do that first thing in the
morning to find out and how did all
those experiences go and I weigh in and
to this day I'm connecting dots because
I care about who our guests are
this one knows that one seat them near
each other this one has just published a
book make sure to go buy that book and
have it on the Matrix stand so they can
sign it
I care about that stuff as much as I've
ever cared about it
but it also means you know getting to
know the community in which you do
business because why should your
community root for your success if
you're not investing in your community
same thing goes true of of our suppliers
get to know your suppliers
you want the best product you can't have
the best business if your raw products
are no good I learned that Lesson by the
way from my grandmother
very very important
I love the cooking in her home
and I'll never forget when I ask for her
tomato sauce recipe and she said
I'll give you the recipe but I'll tell
you one thing right now it's never going
to be any better than the the worst
ingredients you put into it
and number two those ingredients
themselves won't be any better than how
well you treat them after you buy them
so you better get the best tomatoes
which in New York is like a two-month
season
right it's like August and September
and even if you get the best tomatoes
you better not throw them in the back
corner of the walk-in refrigerator and
Bruise them so that they lose their
their sugar treat them the right way
well guess what same thing goes for
people
you can have the best
best recipe in the world for how you
hire people but you better pick the best
tomatoes you better treat them the right
way if you want the best sauce
so I've just learned so many lessons
it's amazing how many life lessons
actually apply to learning your business
another great one that my grandmother
taught me when I was a little kid
growing up in St Louis my favorite
moment was
was March
March and April because spring came kind
of early to St Louis and that's when my
grandmother would plant her her flower
garden she had a amazing Green Thumb
well keep in mind she lived in an urban
apartment building it was a skyscraper
in St Louis it's six stories tall and
her apartment building gave her a plot
of land in the parking lot that was
probably
20 feet long by about
four feet wide
and she called it carbon monoxide
Gardens
and so every spring she would invite me
to come help her plant her garden for
the for the summer and this would always
be probably late March something like
that
and you know this probably started when
I was six years old or something like
that and she gave me my gardening gloves
and she taught me early on to figure out
which were the weeds and I kind of like
that scene from Tom Sawyer and
Huckleberry Finn she was basically
having me do all of her free labor
weeding the garden
so I learned to pick all the weeds so
now by the time I'm about nine
I go down there for my annual spring
visit
and
now it's probably April or May because I
would do this you know as the garden
would would keep growing and she said
now I'm going to teach you the real
secret to how you have a great Garden
and so I go for the weeds dutifully and
she said nope she takes my hand gently
pulls it off the weeds
and she hands me a watering bucket
with some something in it I have no idea
what was in it he says I'm going to
teach you how to water the flowers
because if you really want to get rid of
the weeds the best thing you need to do
is water the flowers because the flowers
will provide a canopy
that will actually
prevent the weeds from getting the
sunlight that they actually need
so
voila best business lesson ever because
I spend the first 10 years of my career
almost exclusively focused on trying to
motivate problem employees
to be better
like the weeds right and what I learned
was that
our employees are like sunflowers they
will turn wherever the sun is and if I'm
spending all of my attention on the
weeds I'm actually pulling the
gravitational force that way
and I my grandmother's lesson was right
if I water the flowers and spend more
time with the people who maybe I've
taken for granted because they're doing
such a great job
they actually crowd out the weeds and
the weeds take care of themselves
I'm definitely going to ask you more
questions about hiring with some some
hypothetical situations but before I
move on the five stakeholders did you
list them and I think it was employees
guests Community suppliers investors in
roughly the order that you would or did
weigh them in your
restaurants exactly exactly that order
it took a long time to figure that out
every business has those same
stakeholders you get to pick in which
order you're going to prioritize them
and
you know
when I went to college and I took
exactly one econ course econ 101 and of
course you learn about Adam Smith and
we studied Milton Friedman a guy from
the University of Chicago and it was
like take care of the investor and
everything else takes care of itself
so I had that voice on my shoulder
but I also you know one of the first
jobs I had after college
I was the
Cook County field coordinator for John
Anderson's independent running the
presidency in 1980.
and leave it to me to work for the
independent guy not the Republican not
the Democrat
but 100 of the people who reported to me
that job by the way I got 214 bucks a
week but 100 of the people who reported
to me were volunteers
and most of them were older than I was
because I was only 22 and
I didn't have any way to motivate them
with money I couldn't give them a raise
couldn't dock them their pay
so I learned such a crucial lesson which
is that if someone's volunteering the
only way to motivate them is to have a
higher purpose we're all doing this
because we agree with this bigger idea
and so basically took that idea to work
with me when I first became a
restaurateur and again half the people
who worked everybody was getting paid
but at least half the people were older
than I was and I was learning what it
was like to be a leader to be the boss
and
I basically to this day treat all of our
employees as if they are volunteers
which is yeah not in the real sense
you're going to get paid but if you're
working for me
it means you're probably good enough to
have gotten another 25 job offers at
least
and so as far as I'm concerned you're
volunteering to share your gifts with us
I better give you a higher purpose and
reason for wanting to be here and that's
when it became clear to me that our
first stakeholder had to be our our own
employees and by the way I look at this
Tim like it's a it's a virtuous cycle
it's it's not a totem pole were the
employees on the top and the investors
on the very bottom
it's a it's a virtuous cycle where one
input leads to something even better so
if you want to have really happy
customers
they shouldn't be the input you should
have really happy employees which I
think then leads to a greater chance
you're going to have really happy
customers you want to have really happy
investors you wouldn't want that to be
the input Mr Milton Friedman you'd want
that to be the outcome and by the way
what's ultimately the best way to have
happy employees
have really happy investors because
that's the only way people are going to
get promotions and raises
and I've run a business where nobody was
getting promotions and raises and it was
not happy
and we had to go out of business when
that happened
I'd like to ask you a question about
writing
and I'm going to begin with a blast from
the past which I've kept for a very very
long time because I think it's so
masterfully crafted and it's something
that you crafted
and this is a polite decline I'm not
going to say rejection a polite decline
when I via a mutual acquaintance close
friend of mine Jeffrey zarovski
reached out to see if if you would
participate in my book tribe of mentors
and the beauty was your response ended
up being incredibly valuable as a polite
decline so I I'm going to be
paraphrasing a bit but this this is what
I received
and it was via Jeffrey who was acting as
the the yenta slash intermediary
Jeffrey greetings and thanks for writing
I'm grateful for the invitation to
participate in Tim's next book project
but I'm struggling at this moment to
make time ends meet for all we're doing
at ushg including my ongoing
procrastination with my own writing
projects I thought carefully about this
and it's clearly a wonderful opportunity
but I'm going to decline with gratitude
know the book will be a big success
exclamation point thanks again Danny so
this is so
noteworthy for me because
there are many ways you can decline
something that are likely to upset
someone or don't do anything to offset
the potential for someone being upset I
came away from receiving this
just laughing and wanting to get better
at writing polite declines because I
felt better about you I respected you
more after receiving that
how did you learn to
write how did you improve or develop
your written communication
I can't believe you pulled that letter
out that's wild
[Laughter]
and you know what I do that almost every
day
but I wouldn't do it if it wasn't if it
weren't genuine I wouldn't have gone to
the trouble of saying all that stuff if
it weren't genuine you know
I've always loved writing my dad
was an amazing editor he was actually
the managing editor of
the newspaper at Princeton the daily
princetonian and he took great pride in
marking up anything I ever wrote
you know I care I love writing I love
expressing myself but I also I think
more to your point it's it's not the
quality of the writing as much as it is
the sentiment behind it which is that
yes if somebody
gets back to what we were saying earlier
if somebody cared enough to reach out
their hand and say I want to shake hands
with you
that's that's what that was or they
reach out to give you a hug what are you
gonna do just become a tree and not hug
them back
and and I think that I've learned a very
very important lesson in fact I'd be
curious and you'll probably know
I care so much about
letting someone know if I do appreciate
an invitation but I just genuinely can't
do it
I care that they know that that their
invitation mattered to me so much so
that I sometimes procrastinate writing
that note and I've learned the hard way
yeah that
that sometimes my mind and my heart are
at war with each other
my mind knows I shouldn't do it my heart
really wants to do it
and if that translates to making you or
Jeffrey wait too long to get that
response it doesn't really matter what I
wrote so I'm really curious to know when
when Jeff's invitation came and how many
days went by before I responded my bed
is more days than there should have been
I don't have the dates but I'll take a
look
has your approach to that type of polite
decline changed over time do you have
other language that you like to use and
again this is not to imply to your point
earlier that this is disingenuous like
the assumption is made and I believe
that it's that it's just it's really
hard but have you found it's it's just
really it is it takes time because
you know what what most people do sadly
is they just delete the invitation
or they just ignore it
um
so I think it kind of falls into a
couple camps here so number one is
is this something I really want to do
number two if I really want to do it can
I do it so that's easy look at your
calendar
and number three
is this something that I feel like I
should do
and and then of the shoulds there's
another couple buckets which is is it a
should because I have to or is it
because
it should because it's good
right I've gotten into most trouble on
the shoulds
if I really really want to do something
like I really wanted to have this
conversation with you today I'm the guy
that reached out to you
and
I love when I get a spark of something
that I really want to do
but
many many times the invitations come in
I get a lot from politicians we use
support this or that I get a lot from
you know speaking opportunities
Etc
and I'm not complaining I'm very very
fortunate
but if it's a should
I learned this lesson from the
restaurateur Jeremy King who's in London
a great guy
and he said
he said the shoulds are what have gotten
me in the most trouble and I asked
myself a simple question
if this thing were tonight
because it's generally something you
know four five six months from now but
if this thing were tonight is this
something I would be excited to do or
would I roll my eyes and go oh man look
what I have to do tonight and so by
making it in the very present that's
really helped me a lot with the shoulds
and then
I just feel like it's not my obligation
to say yes to everybody but I do care I
genuinely care if somebody had the
courtesy to invite me to do something
they deserve the courtesy of a
gracious response all they're guilty of
is saying I'm interested in you how bad
is that that's that's a compliment
it can be really challenging and I just
want to give you
Kudos again for an incredibly
beautifully crafted polite decline that
I was
might sound bizarre but thrilled to
receive I really admired it so much that
I've kept it on hand
and I asked about writing because I I
find that you pay seem to pay a lot of
attention to language and communication
and Clarity and my attention was drawn
in doing homework for this conversation
to questions now you can't believe
everything that you read on the internet
so I do want to fact check this but I
found a list of six qualities Danny
Meyer looks for
when hiring that is and the first is I'm
just going to read through these and
then you can correct as as needed or
expand as needed but I'm going to get to
a few at the end there are only six that
have questions Associated so number one
kind eyes eyes don't lie kind eyes it's
a health start curiosity does this
person see themselves as a finished
product or are they looking to
continually learn three work ethic you
can teach someone how to decant a bottle
of wine but you can't teach them to see
opportunities to do more now we're going
to get into some questions so for
empathy
is this the kind of person the entire
team is going to want to be around ask
on a scale of one to ten tell me how
lucky you are
so I'm curious about that self-awareness
can this person read their own weather
report ask what is the single biggest
misconception people have about you and
then Integrity trust you know ask name
something that happened to you before
the age of 12 that has changed your life
forever
if you were hiring for your first
restaurant today would you ask some of
these questions look for these six
things or or would you modify this I
would absolutely look for those things
in fact I've checked them with myself
year after year and there's not one of
them I would take off the list I want to
work with people who are
kind people
[Music]
who genuinely are optimistic people
I I'm not really excited working with
Skeptics who just yeah see what could go
wrong all the time look I'm a cockeyed
Optimist I'm you know I'm so damn
optimist
that I basically see the wine glasses
half full even before I pull the cork on
the bottle but it's important for me to
surround myself with people who at least
ask me some tough questions so I want
kind optimists I definitely want Curious
people who look at each I don't I don't
want know-it-alls I want learn it all's
I don't want someone who's already a
finished product it's not fun especially
if you're trying to make your business
better every day I definitely want
people who have an excellent work ethic
I don't mean you know to the point of
being sick because we can all push it
too far but
it's not fun to be on a team where
everybody's really bringing their best
and and there's a couple people just
putting in a c-level effort that doesn't
work and I definitely want empathetic
people people who understand the Wake
they leave in their path who care about
how they make other people feel just as
much as they care how other people feel
so yeah and and definitely I want
self-aware people and I want people with
Integrity so 100 of those the one thing
I would add that
has really really come to light for me
is I I want people
who
who just love to win
because because that's not really
captured in any of the six that I
mentioned earlier
wanting to be a champion you look at the
best athletes in sports
sure they have god-given physical
ability but they also had to train like
crazy
you know you don't get to be the
Kentucky Derby winner without you got
your Bloodlines but you also had to
train like crazy you don't get to be
Serena Williams
without the Bloodlines but you don't
also get to be Serena Williams without
working incredibly hard or Michael
Jordan whoever it is you want to talk
about so I look for that I'm really
interested to know the motivation behind
what makes someone competitive and I
basically have four buckets first of all
there's a competitive people people who
are they're great people
they just don't wake up every day saying
you know I gotta win I'm dying to win
Tim Ferriss did not get to be Tim
Ferriss without Desiring to be the best
I know that and that doesn't necessarily
come across but you're not a competitive
I can tell you that then the other three
buckets I look for and this helps me
with someone's self-awareness as well
is to understand
assuming that you are motivated to be a
champion at what you do
what's the what is your primary
motivation for wanting to compete to win
and I find there's basically three
buckets sometimes people have a little
bit of each but there's the
you know that picture of Muhammad Ali's
standing triumphantly over Sonny Liston
whose back is on the Middle with his
fist up in the air so I can pretty much
tell you that Muhammad Ali
was primarily motivated by a love for
beating someone else
that felt really good to him
and that's not it's not a bad thing or a
good thing just is what it is then you
got imagine this photograph of John
Mcenroe with his headband on in his long
curly hair
yelling at the
Umpire you've got to be kidding me
that man hated to lose
it wasn't so much I'm motivated by
who I'm going to beat it's like like I
will not be seen losing
and then the third image I would have
would be
a great Olympian let's say Usain Bolt
and his leg is outstretched with the
veins popping
right trying to get that extra inch or
that extra half second off of his time
or whatever
and that guy is he's out there his
primary motivation he wants to exceed
his own personal best he's competing
with himself so by knowing
these questions this is something that I
would absolutely want to add today
because because I know that I want to be
the best
and I can't do it by myself so I got to
be I gotta stock my team with people who
look at every day as an opportunity not
for Perfection because I think
Perfection is stupid it's impossible
it's a recipe for unhappiness but I do
look for people
who look at every day as an opportunity
to honor whatever they did yesterday and
figure out how to do it a little bit
better today that's that's the Journey
of Excellence
how do you assess this might sound silly
work ethic is it by trialing someone
because everyone's going to be on best
behavior and saying oh my biggest flaws
I just work too hard you know that type
of college application nonsense and a
job interview do you have particular
ways that you would approach assessing
that proactive work ethic right not just
doing what you give them but sort of
thinking about what else they could do
how do you think about it assessing that
well I basically Define it as
you've now learned how to do the job but
only you can determine if it matters to
you to do it as well as it can be done
and you can see it in people
there's so many ways we can all take
shortcuts the obvious things are did you
show up did you show up on time did you
show up shaven if that's what your job
is in the in the dining room let's say
did you press your shirt or just take it
easy and you know get that extra third
third use out of your shirt
where you don't really care what it
looks like and you know it's you see
this in sports all the time and and I
think Sports has so much to teach us
number one is I think in my hospitality
is a team sport we rely on each other
it doesn't matter whether you had a bad
night or not you're not expected to go
strike out if you're a baseball player
it doesn't matter whether you woke up on
the wrong side of the bed or not you're
not expected to let a ball roll through
your legs at shortstop well it's the
same thing in my business your job is to
make the rest of your team better
and your job is to make the rest of your
team better whether you're on the field
or in the dugout and I got a quick story
that that I learned so much from other
people
you've probably heard Theo Epstein in
fact maybe you've even interviewed him
at some point
I have not actually I'm gonna plead
ignorance I I will I will broadcast it
Theo Epstein
is the youngest general manager
in I think the history of Major League
Baseball and he was hired
at a very very young age to take over
being the general manager of the Boston
Red Sox who had not won anything for
decades and decades and decades
and you know they talked about the the
Yankee curse or whatever the hell it was
but for whatever reason they couldn't
win he comes he's the general manager
revamps the team and of course they win
their first
title I I want to say it was in 2004
actually I don't want to say that
because if that's the case it was
against my St Louis Cardinals but he
then went on to go win a couple others
for them and then he leaves to go to the
Chicago Cubs
and the Chicago Cubs guess what they
have not won a World Series forever
he revamps their team
Chicago Cubs win a World Series for the
first time in in all these years so now
this this Wonder can Theo Epstein is
asked by a lot of people
and he's basically you know what what's
the secret here and you got to
understand baseball is a game of
Statistics they measure everything they
their statistics I don't even begin to
understand
but a hundred percent of those
statistics are what's happening on the
field
right so running
caught stealing you're you're Fielding
percentage your batting percentage your
batting percentage with Runners on base
your batting percentage against
left-handers right-handers on and on and
on and on half the game of baseball is
played while you're sitting on the bench
right your team is
your team is in the field you're on the
field when your team is at bat you're on
the bench
and so the real question is how do you
measure what your impact is on the rest
of the team when you're in the dugout
did you help the rest of your teammates
get better
so I've been watching this guy Theo
Epstein trying to learn from him and
finally I have the chance to meet him
once
and he had given a talk at a conference
I attended and it was the year that
there was a big hurricane in in Houston
I want to say it was Hurricane Maria but
I'm probably wrong about that and that
this was like a week after the World
Series Houston won the World Series that
year beating the Los Angeles Dodgers
and so and and he was still with the
Cubs the Cubs had lost to the Dodgers in
the championship series that year
so the team that the Cubs lost to went
on into the World Series and lost to
Houston so I go up to Theo Epstein I
finally get a chance to talk to this guy
who I've been learning from from afar
and I asked him the stupidest question
in the world
and I go
who are you rooting for I got to know
who are you rooting for in the World
Series were you rooting for Houston
because you felt bad for the city
because they just had this hurricane
and you wanted to see something nice
happen for Houston
or were you rooting for the Dodgers
because it would make the Cubs look
better if the team they lost to went on
to become the champion
and he looks at me like I'm from Mars
and he goes he goes actually very
politely he goes actually neither one of
those things
I was absolutely rooting for the Dodgers
to win but not because it would make the
Cubs look better it's because if the
Dodgers win the World Series
I know that the Cubs have to face them
eight times next year during the season
and if they win the World Series they're
going to be like every other team that
wins the championship and they're not
going to do the things they need in the
off season to improve their team
and that's going to make them easier for
us to compete with next year
I want that is such a great lesson
because
it's like when you when you think you're
doing well or you think you're on top of
whatever profession that's the time you
got to break the glass
and you got to start over and that's
when when I think most of us and it's
not just laziness and it's not just
sitting on your laurels it's you think
it's great but the world keeps moving
and if you don't keep moving with it you
will definitely not keep up
that is a great story and
I'd be curious to know I mean did you
dig into or have a chance to study
how he assessed things that were not
captured in the usual stats people
showing up early to practice may be
staying later practicing a b or c
were there any other particular
approaches that you've gleaned from
studying him or speaking with him you
know it was all intuitive to him and
it's the stuff I was looking at on our
team the character
like in my business this is going to
sound really trite but
our staff the cooks and the servers sit
down and and have what's called family
meal before every lunch service and
before every dinner service
and it's an opportunity for people
to come together stop we call it family
meal we are a business not a family but
you can watch during that time
you can just watch who's bringing
motivating thoughts to the table who's
actually bringing outside ideas to the
table who's asking questions
you can tell who's bringing the
conversation down there's always someone
on every team who's who's the ain't it
bad person right yeah
that's not someone we really want in The
Dugout I want people who are like just
imagine if we I want that person just
imagine if we could do this kind of
person
but I didn't study that in Theo except I
watched how
you know before Theo Epstein the most
famous general manager was a guy named
Billy Bean who famously rebuilt the
Oakland A's
protagonist of Moneyball exactly who
might recognize that and I think what
Theo did was he added the emotional
aspect to the technical aspect
um
so let's say you have someone on your
team you don't want in The Dugout and
let's say there's a reality TV show
where you put on a Groucho Marx
makeup kit and you go and you're
starting a new restaurant you can use
all the knowledge you have but you can't
use the contacts you can't use the if
the bankers and the financiers or
whatever you might have had access to
before and you have to let somebody go
how do you make that decision is it made
quickly
do you have you set rules for yourself
as to how to go about doing that and
then what is the what is the language or
approach that you might use well I've
gotten much much better at it as the
years have gone by I mean I'll never
forget the first people I had to fire
when I was 27 28
I'd lose sleep for
days literally days
I even went on my honeymoon knowing that
I was going to have to fire someone when
I came back from my honeymoon and I
really regret that I really regret that
I hadn't done it ahead of time because
that's not something that I should have
been thinking about on the honeymoon
and it you know the early days I really
looked at our businesses if it were a
family and
again the way I grew up it's like my job
is to keep the family together and I
would I'd be great at
somebody wasn't working out at one
position I'd find a different position
and move them to
anything to keep them because it felt
like I had somehow failed if someone was
leaving our company
and I was really really good on the
other hand at rewarding great
performance but I was pretty damn bad
and or slow at exiting people who
shouldn't have been on the team
so a big thing happened over time
and not not too far on the rearview
mirror either and that was this thing
that I've already alluded to which is
that
number one it's a business not a family
one of the great things about the
restaurant business is that it does feel
family-ish to people because you spend
so many damn hours working with each
other
but it's not a family and so it's a good
thing but it's a double-edged sword
because
when you fire somebody from the family
also known as your restaurant you have
to ask yourself what will this do to the
fabric of of that group that troop
that's working together so I was able to
come up with the help of
some restaurateurs in in California
they gave me this model that that I just
absolutely love
and we've turned it into something that
we do and they basically created
a four quadrant thing you've seen these
axes many times with a y-axis and an
x-axis
and
in one of the quadrants there's the word
can
let's say the upper left hand it says
can and then in the upper right it says
can't
and then in the bottom left it says will
and in the bottom right it says won't
so you basically have someone's
technical abilities the Canon can't and
then you have somebody's emotional
willingness or aptitude and that's will
and won't
and so what we've been able to do we've
actually created mirrors
which we put in the locker rooms of our
restaurants and because we're not trying
to keep this a secret
and
The Mirror Has all four quadrants and so
when you go put on your uniform every
day
you get to look at yourself in the
mirror if you so choose and see this
quadrant
and so
basically
if you have someone who
will
but can't
that's a very different thing than
someone who won't and can
right or if you have someone totally who
you know I could go through all of them
but what we've basically done Tim is
that we have an action point and a time
frame for each one of those
so if you've got somebody
who
can and will
right
I want to celebrate that person I want
to replicate that but I really want to
pay attention those are my flowers I
really want to water them
too often we ignore those people because
oh that's easy we don't have to worry
about Johnny because he always gets it
right right you really want to water
those flowers and celebrate them
if you have someone who
can't but will
I'm going to coach them and I don't mind
saying this but the wick on my candle is
pretty long for someone
who will
right because if you can teach them how
to do the thing
and they're willing to do it and they've
got the right approach the right
Hospitality attitude
once they learn how to do it you're
going to have a loyal employee for life
because you stuck with them
now on the other hand so let's say
that's a six month wick on my candle but
let's say you've got someone who can't
and won't
right right I'm gonna put the candle
underneath their rear end
and they're gonna they're gonna have to
learn that this isn't working and and
that's going to be a very very short
that's got to be a short window because
the longer that person stays on the team
everyone else on the team says
why should I try if they keep
if they keep batting that person in the
lineup
instead of benching them or saying to
the minor leagues why should I try
the hardest one I find is the can but
won't
that's the person where you just go you
know you're way better than this but for
some reason you're just choosing not to
bring it here and so yeah that's gonna
that's gonna have a pretty short life as
well but by by actually naming all four
of those things it really really helps
us to have these conversations and we
tell people up front so you're not
having they see that mirror
so it's not the first time you're having
this conversation it gives you a
language to say
here's where you are right now and it's
not working and I'll say probably the
greatest lesson I've learned
about
anything has been really trying to
understand how to use scale culture
and I've kind of come up with this
equation of my own mind that
took me a long time to get to I used to
think that
by rewarding the behaviors I wanted that
was the best way to fuel the culture I
wanted and now I look at it a little bit
differently because
that's turning a blind eye sometimes to
the behaviors I don't want
right so I've now learned that the
culture you have in your organization
is the sum
of all the wanted behaviors that you
celebrate minus All The Unwanted
behaviors that you tolerate
and
I've learned that the hard way because
people think I'm I'm full of crap they
can read anything I write about our
culture Etc but if I'm tolerating
behaviors
that don't promote either the Excellence
or well-being of the team then
everything I've done on the positive
side should be called into question
how might you these days having had much
more practice since your honeymoon
if you if you had to let somebody go or
you wanted to maybe suggest language
that someone might use but you could
make it personal how how might you
phrase that conversation well the first
thing is it shouldn't be the first time
you've had the conversation yeah there's
nothing worse than when somebody feels
like I got whacked in the back of the
head and and they're just shocked
because you had never had the
conversation you hadn't had the tough
conversation that said
either your performance or your behavior
it's one of the two
are not Measuring Up and that's another
reason that we have to be really clear
about what excellent performance looks
like and what The Wanted behaviors are
which we're very very clear about
and
by being upfront with people and not
having this be the first time you're
having the conversation it takes a lot
of the emotion out of it doesn't mean
someone's going to be happy but
it's it basically sounds like
actually
something that
I've said on a few occasions
not in the time I'm actually exiting
somebody but in the time leading up to
it is I use what I call the jigsaw
puzzle
analogy
we've all done jigsaw puzzles and like
the more challenging they are you get to
this point where
it's starting to take some shape but you
still have a lot more pieces
that you haven't put together then what
you have in your little shape there
and invariably you're going to come up
with a piece
that looks like it's right
and you put it down
and it's almost right
it's so almost right that you keep kind
of jiggering it around
to make it right even though you know
it's not right and the piece knows it's
not right and what starts to happen is
the paper on top of the jigsaw piece
starts to fray a little bit
and in fact the jigsaw puzzle if you're
not if you keep trying starts to fray
well that's what we do too often with
employees that are almost right
but they're not really the right fit and
it ends up not being good for the puzzle
or for the puzzle piece
so I try to explain that to people
if you get that conversation with me
chances are probably 80 percent that the
next conversation is you're a beautiful
jigsaw piece but you should probably be
part of a different puzzle
it doesn't make you wrong doesn't make
you bad no if it's someone who actually
did something bad that's a very
different conversation it's like you
cannot work here you've betrayed
Integrity you've betrayed someone on our
team you've betrayed one of our guests
you've betrayed our investors whatever
whatever if you cross any one of our
stakeholders
that's a very different conversation
lack of Integrity but if it's if it's
just not the right fit
it shouldn't be the number one it
shouldn't be the first time they've
heard about it and
they may not love the conversation
who in the world wants to be exited yeah
but I'll tell you one thing I feel
really good about is that we have a
pretty small industry
and invariably if you're someone who
left our business on your terms or on
our terms
you're probably going to be serving me
in a restaurant sometime in New York
and I feel really good that I never mind
seeing these people it just feels like
as long as it's clean and we were honest
with each other it tends to work out in
the end
reading your bio looking at the
highlights and you've had so many
successes
but imagine Beyond Your Wildest Dreams
or expectations that you could have had
in your say late 20s
what are some of your
favorite failures or any favorite
failures that come to mind and by favor
failures I mean a failure that you
learned a lot from that set you up
unexpectedly for later success anything
that's that sticks out comes to mind as
a seminal moment a teaching moment many
many many
every day we have Micro failures you
know there's a really good movie called
The Best Exotic Marigold Hotel I don't
know if you've ever seen it I haven't
watched it it's a terrible title because
I can almost never remember it but I
want to say Carnation chrysanthemum but
it's The Best Exotic Marigold Hotel
takes place in India
and there's two great lessons from that
one of which I think answers there's
probably more than two but one of my
favorite lessons
is that the only real failure is the
failure to try
and that the measure of success is how
we cope with the disappointment
I like that ladder and so I'd say that
probably the first most pivotal
experience for me was
closing the first restaurant I ever
closed which was Tabla an Indian
restaurant interestingly
interesting that I'm using an Indian
film to talk about this but
Tabla was about 13 years old
and if I regret one thing that I wrote
in setting the table it was actually in
the very first paragraph of the book
and I proudly stated at this at this
point we had been in business for about
20 years and I proudly stated how many
restaurants we had opened
and then I super proudly stated and in
all that time we've never closed one
as if closing a restaurant is failure
and it was the stupidest thing I could
have possibly written because
closing a restaurant is not failing and
it's nothing it's also nothing to be
ashamed of and
nothing to be proud of to keep a
restaurant open forever it either it is
or it isn't
so
Tableau I guarantee you I was so
falsely proud with what I had written
that I kept Tablo and I was so afraid of
my dad's you know I didn't want to go
down the path of being my dad you
telling me that something I couldn't
make something work here
Tabla was a great Indian
expression with you know in a very
groundbreaking way in New York City
using fresh green Market ingredients we
had a fantastic chef
who sadly died during covid Floyd cardos
groundbreaking restaurant lived for 13
years probably should have closed it at
year 11.
we had just hit the Great Recession
and
we started to lose money
it was our biggest restaurant
in terms of numbers of seats we had 283
seats on three different dining rooms
two different levels
I was so afraid of closing it so afraid
of talking to the team and saying we
couldn't make couldn't make the
restaurant work that I kept it open for
two years longer than I should have
and that was the restaurant where
for two years we had people working
out of loyalty no one was making a raise
no one was getting a promotion
and
I finally gathered the courage to do
what I should have done two years sooner
and
I'll never forget the day I I said look
what if we could distinguish ourselves
as much based on
how well we closed a restaurant as we
had with how well we had opened the
restaurant
and and so we started writing a list of
all right what are all the ways that we
could look back on this and say we did
it the right way
and first thing was
we told our whole staff
right now that sounds well why is that
such a well sadly in in our business
sometimes the first time a staff learns
a restaurant's going out of business is
the day they go to work and see a
padlock on the door because the
restaurant is dead afraid
that no one will work there no one wants
to stay on a sinking ship so we told our
staff quarter of year ahead of time
told our landlord told the community
we invited all of the alumni of the
restaurant in to come cook with us
so we celebrated the restaurant
we hosted job fairs for all of our team
members
not just not just with us teaching them
how to interview and working potentially
in our other restaurants but again
inviting
famous chefs who had once cooked with us
or general managers who had once worked
with us to come in and hire our staff
we hosted three fundraisers we we
brought in Indian chefs from around the
country to do a fundraiser for
earthquake victims in India we did a
fundraiser for Madison Square Park so by
the time this was done we paid our
landlord everything
we actually even paid our investors like
I think they got a
0.1 percent return on their original
invest they got all their money back
plus a couple pennies
so if you're going to close a place at
least that was the way to do it and the
biggest learning I had was there's no
shame in closing
since closing Tabla
I would say we've probably opened 15
restaurants and we've probably closed
another six
and we had to close about three of them
during covid
and I think that learning to fail fast
and realize that if you hadn't tried the
thing in the first place
there would neither have been success or
failure so the real failure would have
been not in trying
but not everything has to go on forever
the late restaurateur Joe Baum had this
great expression
that I love and I don't love but he used
to say
that the definition of a classic
restaurant is one that can outlive its
original lease
and that's you know that was a goal of
mine for a long long time and we've
frankly we've done that with almost all
of our restaurants
I now have a different goal of my own
which is I want our restaurants
and I think your podcast is this as well
and we all have songs in our lives that
are like this or pieces of art or movies
or books but I want our restaurants to
become essential in people's lives I
want people to say my life got better
because that restaurant existed doesn't
matter how long
and and God forbid the restaurant goes
out of business I want people to say I
just lost a little something when that
restaurant closed there's so many
restaurants
dry cleaners whatever they come and go
and it's like who cares there's so many
songs and I never heard it again I'd be
fine but there's this handful of songs
that when I listen to them
I'm grateful for the person who wrote it
I'm grateful for their life my life got
better because that song existed
and I can't even imagine my life if that
song had never been written that's my
more than longevity it's essentiality
that I think matters
you know I haven't thought about this in
a really long time but I still remember
every restaurant and coffee shop in
which I wrote my books because these
locations and I took
great pains to find the right spot
became my surrogate family for a period
of time while I worked on these things
that of course became a huge part of my
life continue to be a huge part of my
life and even though some of them have
gone out of business
or I shouldn't say gone out of business
maybe they were just closed maybe the
decision was made to close
they still have left this indelible Mark
in my mind and I just brought all of
these These Memories rushing back like
the Pixar movie Ratatouille the similar
effect just now as you're talking about
that and I I admire you for
being in my mind an experimentalist
running experiments being willing to try
in terms of testing things and I
remember
this was some time ago you could
probably place the the time stamp
effectively but when you experimented
with no tipping
and I would love for you to speak to
that and just discuss Lessons Learned
through that
and this ties into something we were
talking about a little bit before I
recorded which was time in Japan where
tipping is not a thing as an example
it's just not really part of the culture
but could you describe what you what you
did and what you learned yeah we had
faced a major major
shortage in really good Cooks this was
this was probably starting in about 2012
2013 2014.
and
I'll never forget I went to one of the
restaurants we closed which was a really
good restaurant but I think we got a
subpar location for it was called North
End Grill
and
I'll never forget going into the
restaurant one night and I
I said to our general manager Kevin I
said
got him service has gotten really good
here and I'm so proud
I just I spoke to four different servers
and they all told me that they had
graduated from The Culinary Institute of
America and I said how are we getting so
many people who want to be professional
servers this is great
and he goes boss I wish I could tell you
that was the truth
he said these are all people who wanted
to be Cooks but they can't afford to be
Cooks
and you know there's like three of them
living in a studio apartment commuting
all the way from Queens and we can't pay
them any more money because we don't
have any more money to pay them we're
trying to give them you know like free
Metro cards but that's not going to keep
them so the only way they can make a
living is to be Waiters
and
something I'd been thinking about for
many many years was how much I did not
like the Tipping system initially in the
early part of my career
I didn't like the Tipping system because
there would always be a situation in
these early days of Union Square Cafe or
Gramercy Tavern when
you know a tourist from Japan or from
France
or Great Britain where there's not a big
tipping culture
would either leave no tip or they'd
leave a you know pretty shitty tip and
it would be so demoralizing for the for
the waiter there was one occasion where
one of our waiters actually chased
somebody out on the sidewalk and I was
mortified it's like you cannot do that
and yet here I was because of the
Tipping system where they were getting
the adjusted to minimum wage back then
which was 2.21 cents
and if they didn't get a tip they
weren't going to be able to pay their
rent so I understood it but it was just
I hated it but then later
now you know bringing it up to the the
mid 2015 time
I said you know what I'm so tired of
this system where we are legally
prohibited
from allowing tips to be shared between
waiters and Cooks Cooks work at least as
hard as Waiters right the guy who made
the risotto
didn't work stirring the risotto like
crazy didn't work any less hard than the
guy that brought it to the table
and and by the way if somebody's going
to have truffles shaved on that risotto
and therefore the price is going to go
way up the waiter is going to make a
whole lot more money and the cook's
gonna make zero more money
and and what I had noticed was that
every year
the waiters were making increasingly
more money why well because menu prices
only go up and what's a tip if not a
multiplier of the menu price
and Cook's hourly wages
had remained stagnant
and and so you may say well why don't
you just raise the cook's wage
great every time I raise the cook's wage
I have to increase the menu prices which
only increases the disparity because now
the chipped employee makes more
so I was really tired of trying to argue
that New York state or many many other
states should change their laws so that
tips can be shared
and so I said screw it I'm just going to
take this into my own hands and I came
to a meeting one day with my senior
leaders and I played one of the worst
John Lennon songs I've ever heard
called cold turkey
and I said I am now declaring tips to be
a drug and we've got to get off this
drug
and if we can't change the rules we're
just gonna we're gonna stop taking tips
and we came up with this idea called
Hospitality included
and my goal was that we would narrow the
gap between
what a cook could not make and what a
server could make I didn't want to
punish our servers but I wanted our
Cooks to get to make more money so we
could attract more Cooks otherwise New
York City is the preeminent dining
capital in America was definitely going
to be threatened
so
we established this idea
did some really really hard math and I'm
telling you it was incredibly hard
because you've got three legs on the
stool you've got the consumer who's
looking at menu prices that now include
everything so if you go to a typical
restaurant in America the menu price
has to include the cost of whatever it
is that menu item is right the chicken
and everything that came with it it's
got to include the cost of the linen the
flowers the rent the insurance
right
it includes everything except paying the
person who brought it to your table
you're going to pay that
two and a half hours after you start
your meal you're going to get your bill
and then you're gonna go into your other
pocket and add 20 to that
but you're gonna do it
so with hospitality included I said
everything's included
and I purposely called it Hospitality
not service because the way I look at it
is
I want you to feel like you're paying
for how we made you feel
I want the food to be free the drink to
be free and when you look at that big
number at the bottom of your thing you
got to feel like man I just got a 350
hug
right and so that's why I wanted to call
it Hospitality included and I wanted our
staff to understand that and so the math
was really hard because by the time I
included everything on the menu price
right
I don't want to bring our waiters down I
just want to bring our Cooks up by 20 oh
by the way
I also wanted to bring our starting
manager salary up because one of the
worst things about the Tipping system is
that you cannot afford in most cases to
promote yourself from being a great
server to being a manager without taking
a 25 pay cut and that that's really
screwed up that there's nowhere to grow
it's a dead end for for waiters unless
they're willing to decide we're going to
raise our manager's wage oh by the way
we're also going to put in a retirement
plan for our team we're going to put in
a family leave policy so that when
people are pregnant
or people have a baby both the birth
mother and the birth father can get up
to eight weeks of paid time off
wanted to put all that in the price
and we didn't want to scare people away
from dying at our restaurants
and we wanted to leave some money for
our investors
so we tried it at one restaurant the
modern really hard but it worked pretty
damn well
amazingly the guests did not bulk they
loved not having to buy their coat back
from a code check at the end of the meal
because everything was included
and then like every every four or five
months we'd roll it out at another
restaurant and we started to see our
our profit started to erode a little bit
but damn it I was gung-ho on making this
thing work because the good news was we
were getting better Cooks
and I knew we were doing the right thing
there's another thing that I should add
is that in in making this choice we
actually had to forgo
a million dollars in federal tax credits
like real money that they pay us
the federal government pays you to
accept tips
I know does that seem crazy or what and
once we eliminated tipping we had to
forego those that and the reason they
did that is that probably 15 years ago
when the government realized they were
not collecting a lot of
taxes based on tips because people were
hiding what they were making
they actually brought the restaurant
industry
under under their cloak and they said
if you guys for every tip dollar tip you
report to us that your servers are
making
we will pay you back
a certain percentage
and so that's why they pay restaurateurs
to take tips because they want the tips
reported but so we gave up a million
bucks in making this choice I just
wanted to do the right thing so now all
of a sudden
covet happens we're basically brought to
our knees with no revenues at all for
four months
could have gone out of business
and
had to lay off a huge number of our team
members so finally in the summer of 2020
New York made it
legal to open your restaurant with a
certain number of outdoor tables Europe
weren't going to make any money but it
was going to helpfully get the city back
up on its feet and
and I was a big proponent for the city
for a whole industry
and I saw this really amazing Dynamic
happen to him
the New Yorkers who had been
locked up in their apartments for all
these months unable to go to restaurants
they could only get curbside pickup and
you know delivering that kind of thing
we're so incredibly grateful for our
servers who are willing to come out and
serve them on the sidewalk that they
were literally throwing
twenty dollar bills at our servers fifty
dollar hundred dollar bills to say thank
you
and now I'm telling our servers
not only can you not accept that
but you have to tell our guests you may
not say thank you to me
after about two weeks of this I said and
by the way we had no vaccine at this
point so any server working there
serving someone who's not wearing a mask
while they're eating
this was a dangerous time in New York
and I I finally said this is inhumane
this is not being on our employees side
and so I said guess what
we're going to resume tipping
but
in so doing
we as a company will start to pay
a percentage of our Revenue every night
to our Cooks who are tip ineligible
I don't think that should be our
responsibility but I did not want to
erode the gains we had made and so now
that's where we are so our servers are
making tips
and if we have a really busy night our
cooks are really happy they're
benefiting they're not just like in so
many restaurants where on a busy night
you're watching the waiters counting
their tips and the cooks just perspired
more that's not right
yeah
I grew up earning my keep on Long Island
as a kid I probably started really young
God I was I don't know 14 or 15.
working as
a busboy and I occasionally if the
moment presented itself a server at
restaurants on Eastern Long Island so I
grew up as a townie in the Hamptons
which has this whole set of stories for
another time
but I'm wondering as we think about
the four quadrants that you described
earlier right the the Ken and will the
can't and won't and the other
permutations
did you run into or how did you handle a
dynamic where people who in the previous
Paradigm so now I'm talking about in the
in the hospitality included transition
you're already there but people who in
the in the Tipping environment had been
top performers
contending with that right so the
sunflowers that you want to water how
did you how did you contend with if you
did the dynamic of maybe prior top
performers feeling like they were not
going to earn their fair share it was
really tough and
you know if you want to take a
Communications lesson just try rolling
out Hospitality included at your
restaurants because
tipping is such a deeply
held American way of life both for the
people providing the service and for the
people on the receiving end this was a
really tough thing to break and and not
many restaurants joined us in this a
couple tried and a lot of them followed
their hand well before we did on the
whole thing but what we did do and I
feel really good about this was to do
the same thing we do with our Cooks so
you get a raise based on Merit if you're
a cook
if you're a server
you're getting the same adjusted minimum
wage no matter what you do
and so we created learning opportunities
with our teams and we had several tiers
of
of learning opportunities and if you got
to a different tier you got a higher
base wage
obviously we were not doing tipping so
you could actually get a raise through
the whole thing so if you look at our
staff we factored in longevity but
sometimes the longest serving servers
are the ones that most need to go
because they're just over ripe and
they've lost their smoke but we
definitely factored in longevity because
here's the thing the way you make the
most tips in a restaurant
is generally through longevity because
you get the
classically the Thursday Friday Saturday
shifts and classically you don't get
them Monday Tuesday lunch right kind of
thing what was great and this was a win
for everybody
was that
that while longevity would factor into
your base rate
it did not factor into your schedule and
so a lot of people who in order to make
their money had to work weekends
sometimes away from their family
they could actually have a schedule that
was a much better balance of life so
there were some wins in this but at the
end of the day we just couldn't make the
math work and
and it just didn't seem right to tell
our staff stop
you know you you must tell our guests no
thank you that was that was a pretty
awkward thing and you know going back to
Japan for a minute they have a wonderful
culture very different from ours and
they call it omotenashi
which is their word which is so much
more than Hospitality it's the providing
of
hospitality and service without
expectation of any further reward in
anticipation of someone else's needs and
it's it's a beautiful concept and that's
that's how that culture has been brought
up
and I've learned a lot from it but it's
I I do believe that the kind of people
we hire who we call 51 percenters people
have a high Hospitality quotient
genuinely are happier themselves when
they do something that makes you feel
good but that's no reason that they
should be penalized relative to this
Marketplace in terms of how much money
they can make
what is 51 refer to well we want a
hundred percent employee just like all
of our employees would like us I want to
get 100 on my test
I think that happened probably three
times when I was a kid but doesn't mean
I didn't want it and so it's our way of
basically saying great you want 100 on
your test here's how you get it cool
thing is there's only
two ingredients in this recipe
there's your technical performance how
well you do the job you're paid to do
the most points you can get for doing it
perfectly is 49.
then there's your hospitality
performance that's and how did you make
everyone else feel while you were doing
it that's worth 51 points that's I think
we both know 51 is a little more than
49. I don't want to get a 51 on my test
that's a failing grade if I don't do the
technical stuff right the food sucks or
it took too long doesn't matter how nice
I am right I'm 100 but I will tell you
right now that
the only way I've learned to become
essential and to burrow our way into
people's hearts is
food better be damn good
but more than anything else you got to
feel like we're on your side and that's
where the 51 comes in I love that
Danny I'd love to ask you just a few
more questions and one that comes to
mind you seem to be I have to imagine a
a reader and besides your own books what
books have you gifted the most to other
people
if any come to mind or gifted frequently
well outside of our cookbooks and
setting the table which is the most most
gift I give because someone's got to
give it
I love marketing I just love marketing
because marketing is understanding the
other person
marketing is a dialogue it's a lot like
hospitality
and I love Seth godin's books and I
would say that I've given many of his
books but probably the one that I've
given the most is this is marketing and
it comes down to one simple
Express he's just so brilliant it
you know getting to the essence of of
what something really is and and he he
thinks marketing is
when you can convey that people like us
do things like this
and that sounds so simple and yet it's
so deep actually I believe that the
biggest longing people have is to be
long
and so great marketing actually
doesn't just sell you something it makes
you feel like you belong to a tribe
so anyway long answer to your question
but
yeah
that would be the one
Seth also walks the walk I really am a
huge fan of Seth and I've gotten to know
him over the years
very sweet guy always will tell you
exactly what is on his mind you don't
have to guess which I love makes me Pine
after the East Coast every once in a
while when I have to deal with the
opposite somewhere in the US I hope Seth
won't mind this story but he once told
me exactly what was on his mind he had a
pretty bad service experience at at one
of our restaurants myolina
and he told me
and I've known Seth for a while loves
love him
and
I felt so badly and I said I gotta write
a great next chapter on this I gotta
figure out something so
I invited Seth to have breakfast with me
at myalino
and
he didn't want to talk about the service
mishap he said I gave you what I gave
you the gift you go deal with that's
your problem go go figure that out I
just want to have a good conversation
with you so we had a great breakfast and
I'm going all right finally finally got
set back and my good graces here as he's
leaving the restaurant
after breakfast
I don't know what happened but he banged
into our clear door the door was so
clean that day he banged into it and
broke his nose
and I'm going now what am I gonna do
here
of course Seth anyway he's a genius and
he is he is the definition of a mensch
yeah he really is and he's he's one of
the best people I've ever met at
walking the walk with
what he describes or his values whether
publicly presented or not he's very good
at
defining his values and I don't think he
would think of it this maybe explicitly
but sort of rank ordering them and then
organizing his life making decisions
about family business Etc travel that
are aligned with all of those it's very
impressive I I aspire to be better at it
certainly
leading off of the
the very pithy and very I think accurate
also expression regarding marketing from
Seth if you could put anything on a
billboard this is metaphorically
speaking just to get a message out
could be
an image could be a quote it could be a
word could be anything at all just to
convey something to a very very large
number of people is there anything that
you might put on that billboard
can't we please have a charitable
assumption about one another
I think I'd put that on there I I feel
like when we go into a a conversation
with somebody or read about somebody
and we assume the worst
as the starting point it doesn't usually
end up very well
on the other hand when you assume the
best intentions
you just never know it's it's very
possible that
you hadn't communicated understood
what what someone really meant and I
feel like going into
any relationship or
experience with a charitable assumption
is such a helpful thing
is that something that you've had out of
the box you mentioned the the glass half
full even before you Uncorked the bottle
but in this particular context going
into say conversations
having charitable assumptions as opposed
to assuming the worst is that something
you've cultivated is it something that
just seems to come with your hard wiring
I just think that's who I am ah
I I don't think it's something I've ever
thought consciously about
but I do know that
it's not just about being optimistic but
it's it's about being hopeful there is a
difference between hope and optimism I
think that hope is an active Act
hmm
look I think it's
so much this gets back to Growing Up
my parents got divorced after 25 years
and I'm watching
all these conversations and and there's
two truths to every single conversation
and
you know I think one of one of the gifts
I got as a kid was getting to cherry
pick the good stuff from each of my
parents and leave the bat didn't make
them bad people it's just like
you pick and choose but you start from a
standpoint this person actually means
well their intention is to do the right
thing
and we're all flawed we're we all make
mistakes constantly but that doesn't
that's not a reason to vilify us and
you know the other thing I'll just say
is that
you've clearly gotten the sense I'm a I
live my life within the 40 yard lines
I don't live my life on the five yard
lines where you can't you can't hear
people yelling at each other from the
five yard lines of a football field
and I know that we've gotten so tribal
in this country so tribal with
everything that if you're not all the
way on one side or the other you're
wrong and that's just not how I look at
life
just gives me great joy to
to find how can we make progress
together and it starts with assuming the
best in people
Denny we've covered a lot of ground and
we're we're honing in on nearly two
hours now or roughly two hours
and as we want to
close is there anything else that you
would like to say or request could be a
request of my audience could be anything
at all that maybe we didn't discuss
you'd like to bring up any closing
comments complaints you'd like to Lodge
publicly anything at all
go support your local restaurants
because and your local butchers and your
local
Fruit Growers Etc you cannot know how
important for the economy
and also for the just the emotional
fabric of a community restaurants are
restaurants provide a place
for
the community to come together
and
do their social life to do their
business life to do their personal life
we saw what life looked like when we
didn't have restaurants during covid
and
it gets to the human desire to connect
with people people are so eager to be
with people and so the more you can do
to
support people who work in the food
industry that that's my hope
I think that's a perfect place
to and Danny thank you so much for
making the time it's really nice to have
a long-form conversation with you and I
appreciate you carving time out of your
schedule to do this so first and
foremost thank you very much I have tons
of notes many things to follow up on
many things to think about which is
always the sign
well I'm really grateful to you and
thank you for sharing me with your
amazing audience and I hope I'll get to
see you in New York
absolutely I do love New York City I
mean there's no place like New York City
or at a Shake Shack near you by the way
at uh the Shake Shack in Austin we have
a burger there that we only do in Austin
no kidding all right I can find that on
Lamar on the south you can find it there
and it's called the Lockhart link
so we got a
amazing sausage from Lockhart Texas and
put it right on top of a shack Burger
I wish we had those in New York but only
in Austin all right that's on my to-do
list and for those who don't know
Lockhart very famous this is
this is one of the meccas of delicious
meat here in Central Texas so I will
have to try the Lockhart link and for
people listening they can find you Danny
on Twitter at DH Meyer Instagram also DH
Meyer we'll link to many many other
things that we've discussed I recommend
people check out setting the table your
book they can find
ushg ushg.com as well as your team
member description and so on and I will
add links to everything we discussed in
the show notes for folks after the fact
and you'll be able to find that as
always at tim.blog podcast and until
next time be just a bit Kinder than you
think is necessary to others and to
yourself assume good intentions make
charitable assumptions about the next
person you're going to have a
conversation with and as always thanks
for tuning in